so good afternoon and a warm welcome to
everybody in the audience at Yale and to
those of you tuning in online my name is
Justin Linden Mayer I'm a third-year
joint degree student between the school
management and School of Forestry and
it's my distinct pleasure to introduce
the topic for the panel discussion today
as well as our moderator Ariel
Schweitzer who is wholefoods senior
global grocery coordinator sitting right
here today's panel discussion food and
sustainability access and impacts is
sponsored by the Yale Center for
business in the environment in
collaboration with the Yale sustainable
food projects in the Yale office of
sustainability and is being broadcast
live through the Yale livestream Channel
and before I introduce Errol I want to
mention that as part of this ongoing
collaboration between Yale and Whole
Foods that we've been referring to today
Lee Kane who those of you who've been
here for the day know who he is he and a
number of his wholefoods colleagues will
actually be returning to campus on
Wednesday November 7th for one of the to
take part in Yale sustainable food
projects chewing the fat speaker series
this year's theme is institutional food
buying and Whole Foods will represent
the retail sector perspective so we
really look forward to that and stay
tuned for more details we're incredibly
lucky today to have Errol service
moderator for this panel of experts who
are as diverse as they are distinguished
in terms of their food expertise over
his 18 years of experience in food
retail Errol has done everything from
coordinating a CSA and co-op market and
managing overnight stock crews to
running the helm of Whole Foods global
grocery program so to say he knows what
makes a product stand out on the Shelf
would be a gross understatement Errol
and his team have brought thousands of
the industry's culinary fines and foodie
treasures to Whole Foods grocery aisles
and through their procurement decisions
have helped lead the charge on ethical
sourcing expanding organic and non-gmo
choices and providing options that meet
every kind of special diet in existence
Erol has also played an integral role in
developing driving and launching Whole
Foods eco scaled rating system which is
the most comprehensive set of household
cleaning standards in the industry
designed to help shoppers make smarter
greener choices for their homes and for
the planet
Errol's passion for food the environment
and business make him an invaluable
asset to the natural and organic
industry and he will be a key player for
many years to come and we're thrilled to
have him here today
so I'd like you to join me in welcoming
him tl thanks dude
hi I'm a product of the State University
System in New York's is an honor to be
up here in the Ivy League's
so my gig at Whole Foods is to be the
global grocery coordinator and we're
responsible for about 30 to 31 percent
of product sales at Whole Foods and what
we've really seen over the last few
years is our focus on sustainability and
green mission and product quality and
transparency has intensified we've just
done better as a program as a team as a
company and so I mentioned before that
it's really core to our business to do
these things and to address these issues
and I really like this program of
bridging academia in the retail sector
as I'm essentially a failed academic I
did apply to a couple of grad programs
and get in so not bitter point is though
to have an intellectual and you know
literate basis you know sort of a
practice of understanding of what you're
doing even if you're a grocer is really
important because the issues are so
intense and you can't have economic
growth on a dead planet you know and so
there's a lot of folks at Whole Foods
who are really passionate about actually
preserving our ecosystems making sure
that we have the healthiest food on
shelf and that our customers understand
down to an ingredient level what they
are buying from us that transparency and
ethical sourcing is so core to what we
do that I couldn't imagine Whole Foods
market without
and so on over the years we've seen
tremendous growth on organic foods we
are America's leading retailer of
non-gmo verified items we've helped
really bring Fairtrade to market in this
country the Eco scale program was four
years in the making basic impetus
there's just tell people what's in there
cleaning products and then creates some
sort of level for helping them
understand what's better and using those
ideas across the store I've actually
it's because of the reading that a lot
of us do whether it's influenced by West
Jackson or Wendell Berry or Michael
Pollan or some of the folks here on the
panel and so I think that this is a
really great initiative that we need to
push forward and so some of the themes
that we're gonna you know try to touch
on today I'm gonna sort of back up and
let the panelists handle our you know
pretty broad I'd like to give everybody
on the panel a few minutes and then open
it up to questions sort of catalyze
further discussions and ideas but some
of the things that we're gonna try to
touch on include you know the aspect of
supply chain you know who are you buying
from what are you buying from how are
you buying it what are the challenges
were the opportunities what are some of
the victories and and you know
benchmarks you've had but also you know
where do we still need to go and I say
that with all seriousness working in a
packaged goods sector I mean we sell a
lot of stuff that ends up in a landfill
in grocery right and so as good as we
think we are now we have to get better
right and so I'm asking the panelists to
touch on that as well looking at local
versus global well work for a national
food retailer we have 337 odd stores
stretched across 34 states local
sourcing is corn intrinsic to what we do
but we also have products that we have
to ship across state lines supply chains
on a local level in terms of working
with the actual producers the challenges
looking at you know the product mix the
quality what the folks in in the area
want to eat and want to buy and that's
different as you get across the country
obviously and how that is how that
affects your ability on a financial
level on an institutional level to make
that happen and then finally I mean once
again getting back to the bigger picture
human health environmental
sustainability
long-term happiness of all the
stakeholders involved and got to keep
all that stuff in mind because what
we're trying to do now you know that
whole notion of the 7 generation right
and I'm not just talking about cleaning
soap which is great product by the way
but the notion that
you know what we're doing now to keep in
mind seven generations down the line
it's a holding of so many Iroquois
saying and I think it's really important
as we're looking at that as operators
and in academics to make sure that we're
keeping that in mind as we do what we do
so I'm gonna pass the mic here to
somebody whose work I've actually read
and come across and I'm honored to be
sitting máxima dr. Kelly Brownell thank
you well I wasn't inspired just by the
few things you said about the work that
Whole Foods is doing and of course
knowing what the the chain represents
and the sort of products that it
delivers to so many people across the
country it's really a pleasure for me to
be here I direct the center a gal called
the Rudd Center for Food Policy and
obesity our task is to work at the
intersection of science and public
policy so we hope to do science that
will be informative to policymakers
helpful in the policy-making process and
useful for the public to learn about in
terms of making decisions about public
policies regarding obesity but about
nutrition in general so we're very
involved for example in school nutrition
policy and what's available to children
in their school lunches school breakfast
in other parts of the school day we've
been very involved in economic changes
that might help improve diet with soda
taxes being probably the most
controversial of those we worked on
various issues like the portion size
proposal by Mayor Bloomberg in New York
City we work very heavily in the area of
food marketing and what sort of products
are being marketed particularly to
children and as you might guess that
most of the food companies are marketing
their worst products to children and
doing so in very aggressive ways
starting at very young ages and
infiltrating a child's life in ways you
couldn't begin to imagine and are so
different from what marketing I might
have been been exposed to as a child so
we're working on these issues trying to
find what the drivers of poor diet and
obesity are and then thinking of
structural changes the government might
make in order to help produce changes
that can affect many many people at the
same time so we know there are lots of
people working at the local level food
co-ops CSA is all these sort of things
are
to help people in the local level which
we believe is very important we want to
support that as much as possible but we
also think there's a constructive role
for state local and federal governments
and in global organizations to play as
well in creating conditions that make it
easy to make healthy choices rather than
hard so is in a pretty obvious example
of that would be nutrition in schools if
you serve crappy foods in schools kids
will eat crappy foods and they're too
tired their diet will deteriorate if you
get rid of those foods and offer only
healthy foods kids will improve their
diet they tend not to overcompensate by
eating more of the other healthier the
less healthy foods later on and so you
get an improvement in diet so you could
work really hard to educate children one
at a time to make healthier choices in
the presence of a bad environment or you
can try to clean up the environment and
that's the level at which we're working
although we realized as I said before
that lots of people doing lots of things
are important I'd like to discuss
briefly a broad issue a global issue and
then one more specific to the food
retailing world on the broad level we we
think a lot about how there are three
major food crises that face the world
and how the people working on these tend
not to be connected with one another and
how that misses a tremendously important
opportunity so the three world food
crises we think about our under
nutrition and hunger I think of them as
opposite or you know different points of
a triangle under nutrition and hunger
would be at one place obesity and over
nutrition would be at a second part and
those two problems now affect about the
same number of people globally it's
about a billion people are
undernourished hungry and about a
billion are over nourished and
overweight by the way some of you
probably know that in countries like
India and China overweight is becoming a
more important health problem than
underweight who ever would have thought
that they would have arrived and you
very often find hunger and obesity
coexisting certainly in the same country
very often in the same city and
surprisingly even in the same households
and so how can we have a world that
produces these food crises like this
when there's enough food to go around at
least
the time being and then the third part
of the triangle is the environmental
impact of modern food production and
each of these is a very important
pressing social problem that needs
immediate assertive aggressive attention
but each of these areas of the triangle
tend to be represented by different
constituencies there are NGOs that care
about one of those but not all three
there are government organizations
global groups that care about one but
not all three and sometimes there and
then very often there are missed
opportunities for the people who work on
these to come together and have a common
voice that could be much more
politically powerful than any one of
them working individually so there's a
missed opportunity there but sometimes
the areas work at cross-purposes and
disagree with one another so an example
would be the controversy over whether
food stamps should be used to buy sugar
beverages and you have the obesity
public health community saying how much
sense does it make for the government to
be spending two three four billion
dollars a year buying soda and then have
to pay for the diabetes that comes from
it afterwards and you have the hunger
community saying that people are already
stigmatized because of being poor and
now you want to take away something from
them that'll stigmatize them even
further both points of view completely
legitimate but if these two sides of
triangle working together you might come
up with some resolution and some policy
solution that would satisfy everybody so
we're working hard to think about how
the worlds could come together at the
three parts of the triangle and how you
could push ahead social movements around
the world that would benefit all three
parts of the triangle and create social
good more rapidly than what you might be
seeing now a more specific thing I
wanted to mention is about food
retailing in my field of obesity
prevention people have been mainly
focused either on individual programs
aimed at individuals at the community
level or working with or opposing the
food industry in a way that will bring
them around to creating better products
and it's only been about the past year
year and a half that the retail sector
has been brought into this discussion
and people have begun to think about
where people buy food and whether those
environments could be changed in a way
that William
diets of the whole population and
certainly changing the product mix in a
given retail environment is one way to
do that with Whole Foods being the
obvious leader in doing that but there's
also a lot of thought to how modern
supermarkets are structured and how they
could be structured differently in order
to encourage healthy choices so for
example what's at eye level for children
would be an example of that and at the
least healthy products are at eye level
for children say in the supermarket in
the cereal aisle which is clearly the
case in most supermarkets now then kids
are going to be drawn to that there's
gonna they're going to exert what's
called pester power to get their parents
to buy these things and then the diet
will be worse and you you guys know this
better than anybody but moving things up
or down one shelf makes an enormous
difference in what people buy so could
nutrition be part of the consideration
about where things are placed I level
for children versus not would be an
example what shows up in encap displays
what's a featured in the aisles where
the or you're checking out and then
there are also nuanced things that
people have begun to think about like
you know the knowledge about modern
super Marcus about the the beats per
minute of the music that's playing in
the loudspeakers and how long does that
keep people in a market and what do they
buy as a consequence depending on the
impact on their mood of that particular
music and so there are a lot of a lot of
these things each one by itself may not
be terribly significant but when you add
them all up there might be a lot of
things that could be done in the retail
sector that help promote health rather
than than undermine it and so there's a
lot of thought now to using the the
supermarket as a learning laboratory if
you will about how health can be
promoted and the supermarket the retail
industry can still a benefit profit and
thrive under those conditions and part
of a part of the task is to change the
demand of course lots of consumer
education and things like that so people
want different foods but also part of
the consideration is can you change the
environment to push some foods over
others and to encourage healthy choices
just make it the easy choice as I said
before so I'll stop there and and turn
it over to my colleague Rafi
Thank You Kelly I know if I'm on the
arrives yourself my name is Raffy Torian
and I oversee Yale dining I don't get to
that very quickly but I know if I'm on
the right panel then when when I hear
other panelists and I and I see and I
learned so much from them and I know
that they already contributed ten times
more than I will ever contribute to the
panel and and I'm already feeling that
way
hearing Errol and Kelly my name is Ravi
Tori and I will figure dining I work
with over five and providing about
fourteen thousand meals a day for
students here in in a different forms
would be 18 residential colleges we had
in our retail operations and convenience
stores and in in our cafes or v18 our
catering operation now our number one
objective is that we are providing high
quality wholesome food and the fact that
Yale University and Yale dining is being
in forefront of this type of dialogue
sustainable food type of dialogue for
quite some time is not it's not a new
thing Yale University started many years
ago with the Yale sustainable food
project that experiment and a project
that introduced a dialogue and
conversation of sustainable food within
the colleges providing food that was
different food that was delicious
you were sourced in a in a sustainable
way and mark most probably will share
more information about that and we've
been doing that for quite some time for
a number of reasons number one is
because the right thing to do number two
is because having awareness within
university you know creating the higher
level of awareness and dialogue
regarding food
where it comes from and how is produced
and it's it's extremely important
because then that conversation finds its
way to the rest of the society and and
the third is you know the students are
they occurring here and they end up in
some land leadership positions in a
country we hope at least and when they
do that then we have a leveraged
position
you know nationally actually to even
further expand this idea of sustainable
food system in our organization we
fundamentally focus in four areas number
one in how we source food and there we
have a number of a specifications and
standards that we're looking for to just
briefly go over some of them is that we
want to make sure that our protein is
not containing any kind of antibiotics
or any non natural products that the
animal actually itself was treated
humanely that we during the course of
their life and how it was processed that
we fundamentally actually do not use too
much protein I mean just use enough of
it we will we actually focus on reducing
animal-based protein in our dining halls
and provide alternative sources of
protein a plant-based protein and so
when we look at our vegetables and when
we look at our dairy products we have
very specific specifications and we
don't buy typically commodity products
we buy always products that are quality
and either organic or local or natural
or one of the specifications that we we
believe that are important for us to
support and I think we do about 40% of
our total purchases currently coming
from that that category of products
then in terms of our material management
we want to make sure that we are
recycling and we are composting but more
importantly that we are reducing the
amount of waste we are controlling our
waste be it pre consumer or post
consumer we have the strategies that we
we will focus on reducing it and when we
actually have waste then we are
recycling and composting we compost in
all our locations and recycling in all
our locations
the third element actually the fourth
element is collaboration and cooperation
we we want to make sure we know we
understand that what we do we cannot do
it just by ourselves so the more people
in in the area that they we live in and
we work are supporting initiatives or
projects that we are focused on the
better we can do and the more impact we
can have and the more resources may
become available to us as a result of
this process we are currently working on
a project that hopefully with its
support of with some funding supports
will focus on developing a symposium
where we look at interstate 95 corridor
and we look at all the non commercial or
not just today I heard there's a
possibility that even commercial buyers
could participate in this process and
look at how many buyers are in and
around of 95 corridor and see if there
there's a possibility that we can come
together and create some specifications
that help increase the demand and and
therefore stimulate the supply side
because one of the major problem that we
have in terms of the sustainable food is
that the demand side is not homogeneous
is not is not really well-defined and
then on the supply side the number one
complaint that you would hear from
from manufacturers and growers that he
cannot they cannot act based on hundred
different buyers that they want to hear
some some stand or some specification
some some value propositions that a
group of buyers will share and then they
will produce accordingly based on those
standards and I think that's an area of
the focus for us and that's where where
we are going to leverage our position in
in terms of the volume buyer in the area
but also a brand name buyer you know
just like whole food has a very very
important and recognized brand name we
fundamentally believe that Yale
University has a very very distinguished
and valued brand name that could be
leveraged in terms of the purchasing and
and suppliers they pay attention because
then they can actually say that we are
serving Yale University and therefore
maybe Princeton would be listening to
them or Harvard or places that they are
in an around Interstate 95 corridor can
help them I think this notion of the
regional food hub it's probably one of
the hardest things that is going on in
sustainable food systems because again
it's not that institutions they don't
have commitment toward this type of food
is the availability that is the biggest
problem here in North which we have only
95 growing days and so and unfortunately
when when produce and vegetables they
grow our students are not around and so
we we are challenged we we have we do
various techniques that maybe later on I
explained some of them but well thank
you I'll end it now because I have my
time is over and I pass it to mark
thank you so much Ruffy my name is Mark
Baum Ford I'm the director for the Yale
sustainable food project I am a pretty
new arrival to Yale actually but I'm
really delighted to be working with a
project which has been around for almost
10 years now it's also nice as you go
from panel to panel I think to see that
there really has been an evolution you
kind of have to take a long term view
but when you think back you realize that
we're not actually just repeating the
same thing again and again we're
actually getting to that key challenge
of how do we take some of these very
very key successes that have worked at
the grassroots level that have worked at
the small scale and actually bring them
up so that rather than being the
exception in a niche they're actually
becoming the rule they're becoming the
new standard they're becoming something
which is accessible and as we look at
who is participating in these panels and
the kind of initiatives that they're
talking about there's a really clear
evolution and there's really clear
indicators of progress in this whole
area it's been mirrored for me a little
bit when I look back mostly through
chatting with people who are actually
here at the time as to the evolution of
the Yale sustainable food project you
might know some of the tales of the
early successes Rafi talked about some
of them they received a whole lot of
media attention because one of the first
things that we worked on was really
turning institutional dining on its head
with a little pilot experiment in the
Berkeley residential dining hall this
was is precipitated by a lot of very
compelling voices in the food movement
Alice Waters played a prominent role in
making that change she's known for using
the phrase seduced them with taste and
in a way this is what we were doing is
we were trying to actually start a new
dialog by using the secret weapon of
really really good food it was the idea
that not only can we get people talking
about what sustainable food is and where
we go over the food system by getting
them around a table but we're also able
to bring in the people who otherwise
wouldn't be there just because they're
drawn by something which is so good so
delightful so compelling that you can
actually have a basis for starting a
conversation and on the small scale it
worked incredibly well
you know it changed the way that
students thought about food it created
an entirely new demand and it completely
changed the way that the world thought
about what institutional dining could be
but if you looked at what would it take
to move that from Berkeley college to
all of yell or even think about what
would it take to move that small scale
success around the country around the
world well then you've got a slightly
more difficult problem and that's the
problem that we passed to Rafi it's not
an easy one because it's not as simple
as replicating the small-scale success
if you just try and repeat the success
of an individual initiative you soon run
into some pretty big barriers you
realize that basically the entire system
is not set up to respond to that you run
into supply constraints you ran into
constraints through the entire
distribution process and so we realized
that okay this wasn't just a matter of
finding a model at a small scale and
replicating it it actually involved
entire food system reform that's when I
would say we started on our second phase
of this evolving project which I think
was really highlighted by the founding
of the Yale farm with the recognition
that we had a whole system to change we
realized that we didn't actually know a
whole lot about this system some of what
I think was the common knowledge or
common wisdom about what was sustainable
and what was not sustainable food
especially the very prevalent and well
understood ideas of is it local is it
organic is it from a small family farm
as we started to get into some of the
details and the analysis of these
systems we realize that it might not be
quite so simple there's a complexity to
this and there's a nuance which means
that you actually have to think about
these problems in a different way and we
didn't even have the base understanding
of how farm production systems worked
among our students among our faculty and
we figured that one of the best ways to
actually tackle this was to actually get
people farming and start to understand
at least some of the underlying concepts
that went into the production of our
food and so that's when we started up
the Yale farm it's still very much the
heart and soul and one of the most
identify about parts of our program it's
just up the hill here and you can come
visit a beautiful day like today it'll
be kind of unforgettable the Yale farm
is a
intensively managed acre right here on
Yale campus it's an urban farm and the
acre has some significance when we
started to untangle the complexity of
the food system if you look at that
statistically average u.s. diet and that
statistically average US farm neither of
which exist but that's the magic of
Statistics then you would actually have
about an acre per person that's what
would take to actually sustain an
American diet using American farming
practices on average for a year and we
can actually start to think about the
opportunities and the limitations when
we're working on that one acre farm at
Yale one of the first things that kind
of catches you when you're out there in
the field and you're actually harvesting
food and you're tasting it right from
the ground is this idea of Wow I could
probably sustain myself on this this is
very delightful and if you had an acre
yeah you could we're an urban society
increasingly so all the new cities that
will be popping up over the next 50
years will be much more typical and
density of what we have here on the
eastern seaboard Manhattan you might
actually have a hundred people sharing
that one acre with you and so you don't
have to do too much of the ecological
math to realize that all of the benefits
that were gaining from urbanization they
owe a debt to farms around the world
many farms farms through the region
through the nation through the entire
world and what we wanted to do was take
the lessons on that very representative
acre and extend them into what does it
actually take to sustain cities and then
we kind of realized that our third phase
needed to take that very important
learning that was happening at the Yale
farm and actually turned that learning
into impact outside of Yale and that's
where we get into our new theme which is
food literate leadership rafi already
talked about this he talked about the
leverage that Yale graduates actually
have and it's true that
disproportionately you find people
coming from this university in positions
where they're making big decisions that
affect a lot of people's lives and so
our hope is is that as they're having
experience at Yale
is that the work in the farm can be
linked with the work that they're doing
in the classroom to actually get fairly
in-depth rigorous academic guidance in
how the food system is working where the
barriers and opportunities are and how
in their own areas of expertise they're
able to make this contribution as I
think high impact food literate leaders
so what's really exciting as we go
through some of these panels and we see
the people who are invited representing
sectors that typically haven't been at
the table before it's just how many of
these food literate leaders there are
and what the potentials are I'm sitting
with four of them right now
yesterday we also had some folks coming
from everywhere as diverse as the
University of Texas to Shake Shack this
was with Yale law to Consumer Reports to
areas of journalism that we're really
pushing all of these areas in between
how do we get the right food to the
right people at the right time how do we
actually reform the food system from
within and in all of these cases you're
finding people entrepreneurs you're
finding lawyers you're finding
environmental scientists you're finding
journalists and communicators who are
having an increasingly better depth of
understanding about what can be done and
they're working on change within their
areas and so this is a really exciting
thing to see and that's exactly the kind
of person that we're trying to actually
get out of Yale into their own
particular areas to make change in the
food system on the ground scale one of
the most hopeful pieces of news that I
read actually this morning before I came
to the panel was that Chipotle had just
signed an agreement with the coalition
of Immokalee Workers ciaw to adopt their
standards for fair labor practices this
is representing over 4,000 workers
mostly based on the tomato harvest in
Florida
Chipotle had kind of been a holdout with
lots of questions as to why and now they
are embracing this and signing up it's
one of these things which is a fairly
bold action fairly collaborative action
I'm really pleased that one of our
students and yfp alum is working with
Chipotle and that's what we're sort of
looking at right now is how come we look
at these areas through business through
civil society where we can make these
collaborative efforts these bold efforts
and make changes and I'm hoping
that that wrap up in that piece of good
news is a nice segue into the work which
Patrick is doing and so I will leave it
at that I really look forward to talking
about some of these other issues as we
get into the panel but I'm hoping that
this vision of food literate leadership
is combining some of what Kelly's
talking about some of what was going on
with Whole Foods and certainly the
challenges of scaling sustainability
that Rafi has been hitting head-on so
over to Patrick at this point thank you
Mark
my name is Patrick Ruby I'm from
Switzerland I'm here at Yale as a world
fellow I am the founder of effort Raza
that's an organization that supports
small-scale farmer that purchase a
stands for fair trade to South America
as I mentioned I'm from Switzerland I
was working in my former life as an
amount of the largest trading companies
and then I realized I was making the
rich richer and the poor poorer what
made me question what I was doing so I
left that job took a sabbatical I went
to Mexico basically to reconsider what
to do with my life when I was in in in
Mexico I I realized that I really like
international trading but it needed to
be fair trading this was the time when
in Europe fair trade just started you
know there was the fair trade bananas
they were the fair trade the Fredric
coffee but they weren't hardly any more
items like seven items so then I thought
okay how can I use my international
trading skills and I started to
investigate about how to small-scale
farmer live what are their challenges
and and and how do they sustain their
lives so I realized that there are
millions of small-scale farmer who sell
their items to to local middlemen soar
what they called coyotes at very low
prices
extremely low prices so so imagine you
are a farmer in the middle of nowhere
you don't know what what the market is
and some middlemen drives up with a
truck and first you just a very low
price and you don't have an opportunity
you know did you depend on those so you
sell at these ridiculously low prices
but what will never allow you to
to reach the system-level subsistent
level or beyond that so when that
started we then formed a cooperative
certified those with fair trade and
organic and we were the pioneers who
exported those fruit to Europe now fair
trade for those who are not familiar
with the concept has like two main
elements one is it guarantees a minimum
price for the grower and there is an
additional premium that is about ten
fifteen percent that is for social
community development projects the
minimum price is defined by what is the
cost of production plus a pre oppressor
a margin for the grower so this is then
a price that the grower will get in any
case that he can basically sustain his
his living cost this goes into the
pocket of the grower now that premium
the ten percent premium goes into a fund
that is for Community Development Pro
projects so with those projects the
grower organization they can decide
democratically what they want to do with
that with these funds and with these
funds in the in the past we have built a
help build handicapped schooled thrilled
water wells Medical dispensaries so all
these projects that in this country the
government provides for but in Mexico
and Peru they're just not there now
it goes without saying that all of that
implies higher costs so a small-scale
grower can never ever compete with the
big players such as dole to get the del
Monte
why because they're much smaller they're
not as if as efficient we guarantee that
minimum price and we do pay that premium
so the question is how can that work on
an economic scale you know and why has
nobody
why has you know and this it also
explains why those growers never could
could could develop themselves now the
reason is that there are consumers who
are willing to pay more for a fair trade
label product now how does so so with
that said it means that system the fair
system can only work because there are
consumers out there who have that
consciousness who go and are willing if
they walk into Whole Foods and they see
the conventional bananas and the future
bananas they're willing to pay 20 cents
more so who is financing that the end
consumer so it gives it gives the
possibility to to the man in the street
the woman in the street to support
underprivileged small scale Grover
through their purchasing power now
we started in Mexico we formed that
cooperative we started with the avocado
we were the pioneers was abakada then we
added many more items and at the
beginning we just exported to Europe and
then it took off very very very quickly
especially in in the UK and then all the
supermarket's they want to die around
supply so what we did then we went to
Peru when the Mexican when the Mexican
production dick declined Peru started so
we over four or five years we fine-tuned
to model how can be very small-scale
grower in an efficient and effective way
and then we replicated that model to
Peru first then we rep replicated at
mode model to Chile then to Argentina
and now we have about over 20 items in
our in our in our fruit basket that we
can offer that is organic and fair trade
certified now let me give an example
but that means now for 40 growers so we
went to we went to Peru and then we
started to work with banana with a
banana cooperative that we started to
develop our our our country manager he's
he's been in the independent business
and so they're the two main elements one
is those small-scale farmers farm a
product because their father was doing
that and their father was doing that but
they never really got agricultural
trading scale agricultural skills you
know to improve fertility of the and
production so this means there is no
there was no possibility that they can
really get a top-quality item so what we
did is we supported them with technical
skills we got in post harvest experts
they really know what does it take
especially now in that in that in that
example for
for the bananas and then the other
element so one is empowerment and the
other element is market is market access
so so in one of these these these these
organizations that we formed they were
selling the bananas to these to these
middlemen and when we started to develop
them and pay them the minimum price we
could pay up to seven times more what
they were receiving before and this was
a total life changer for these growers
so there was this group of 30
small-scale growers and I remember there
was one of the farmers he was like 70
and he has been growing bananas all his
life and so he in that meeting when they
started to export as Fairtrade he came
to me or in the meeting he raised his
hand and said my dream all my life was
to have a bicycle it was 70 he never
could afford a bicycle you know and
after like three months you know where
he got really they got really much more
money for for their product he then said
even now even though I'm not the
youngest anymore but I will with this I
will make my life remove become true and
I will buy a bicycle so when he told me
that I got goose bumps I was so
impressed and I don't get goose bumps
just like that and so it was it was
striking you know it was striking for me
to hear that from from somebody who has
lived in agriculture all his life who
had never a possibility who who was
deprived from all these possibilities
and and so it was striking to see how
the purchase value chain how the
purchasing power ask the consumers you
know can support those those those those
growers that makes it really is a life
changer so it was really striking to see
so so this is why I believe it's very
important that that that consumers
understand what is happening on the
ground you know how your purchase power
can impact small-scale growth and
importance of the collaboration between
all these the producers the export to
the importer Whole Foods plays an
enormous ly important role in that
because you really can change the life
of smoke
drovers thank you so that it's not a
one-sided you know us and you the
audience discussion I'd actually like to
open it up right now to questions and
see you know where you would like to
take this discussion with this panel of
folks so we got one back there but also
ask a quick question here um who's
really pushing who is it the supply
chain pushing the demand or is it the
demand affecting and pushing the supply
who's really forcing the issue thank you
let's go down the line Patrick do you
want to start in the I mean I can talk
for the fair trade and the organic
movement if the fair trade really took
off
- took off in 2005 when I started my
company this was this was when it was
really demand driven so this is why you
know we started to try to replicate our
model as quickly as possible as you know
also the organic organic has been has
been has been growing constantly and I
believe today that as you know as we
live in times of climate change as we
live in times of of all these natural
disasters more people start waking up
and more people start asking themselves
what do they eat you know and want to
look won't want to eat healthy so I
believe that the demand for both organic
and fair trade will increase and on the
back of that is why we try to replicate
our model to include to include
thousands of producers more to can
benefit from those systems so I think
but it is very important that demand and
supply will be aligned
roughy one of the most powerful forces
in a food industry and what drives
actually food industry is the ability to
generate profit and this is for large
scale or small scale medium scale the
ability to generate profit is extremely
powerful force now
industry itself if you ask them what
what keeps them up at night is
innovation how they can be the newest
trend how they can be the most popular
trend and in the forefront and what
keeps them up at night is if somebody
else is doing it while they're sleeping
and so so there is this huge force on a
supply side that they want to know what
is the newest trend was the the newest
happening that can hit the market and
generate a lot of demand around it okay
and to do it in a very very timely basis
but on the other side the demand is also
extremely important I mean you might
have a on the first example I can give
you a whole bunch of example look at
Papa John's Pizza and none of these
products by the way any of these
products I don't endorse I don't like
but nevertheless you know you can see in
less than 10 years the guy has 2,500
units that means in every supermarket
honesty you know who would have thought
that honesty would become so popular I
mean we did we really need another iced
tea but you know through innovation and
to create it both and and took a hope
segment of the market and then on the
other side is the demand demand is very
very powerful force and and that's where
we're trying to focus now because we we
can move the market to produce the kind
of product that we want if you have a
homogenized demand but unfortunately
another price that we can you know we
can we can afford
and and that that's the main thing so I
don't know both are equally important in
different aspects of the industry I want
to take a quick swing at that and just
re-emphasize that as a retailer you know
we're obviously have to report in
quarterly to our shareholders but what
we've really developed at Whole Foods is
a multi-stakeholder model of success and
so a lot of the points that Raffy has
made especially that we listen to our
stakeholders and in a lot of ways what
we've been able to do on the
sustainability is watching what our
customers by watching what our customers
are saying in social media and online
and making sure that not only are we
responding to it but anticipating where
they're gonna go next and for that that
sort of innovation drive is so tied into
sustainability because that is the key
trend that we're seeing Kelly remark
anything you guys want to add tonight is
that one way to create change on the
demand side is to help change social
norms so that people have a different
idea about what it's like to eat food
and if we can change ourselves from a
culture that focuses on the quantity of
food you can buy for the money to the
quality that would be of course a good
start but also things like the portion
sizes and do we care about the story of
the food and all those sort of things
become very important norm changes and
the question is how do you promote as
much of that as possible you know we can
kind of sit around and wait for it to
happen and a lot of it's starting to
happen and kind of occurring organically
if you will and you know that's why
Whole Foods is growing because there's a
larger percentage of the population
every day who cares about this but if
you want to take whatever trend there is
and increase it by a lot then government
has to get involved and that means the
government needs to deal with curriculum
schools and it needs to be what involved
in what foods are served in schools and
what how foods are priced and all those
sort of things government and of course
subsidies and things are a lot of things
governments can do to to help move this
along in in an accelerated way
I did spend a number of years as a as a
vegetable grower before coming here and
my experience there was that it was very
demand driven there was there was a
surplus demand almost everywhere all the
other people that I was working with
were facing surplus demand basically not
able to keep up with it but the
challenge was that there was a couple
barriers to expansion many of which were
infrastructure based which I think left
us always in this question how far can
this go is it going to be a ceiling is
there going to be a saturation point but
it really did seem to be demand driven
from the producer perspective and what's
very interesting is that you look at
supply chain reforms that have been
rolled out especially with regards to
animal welfare especially with regards
to certification verification and supply
chain tracking so many of those reforms
have been orchestrated by civil society
organizations consumer organizations
that have been acting on that demand
side of the equation or kind of I guess
as it's being talked about homogenizing
some of that demand to turn it into a
clear message but I've really seen a lot
of that side playing a considerable
influence
all right uh in the back here I have a
question and hopefully there's enough
bright people here that can answer by
the way I'm Nyssa and I'm somewhat
affiliated to fair trust that I've been
a buyer of his goods for many many many
years and I've been in the organic
produce industry for about twenty we
talk a lot about demand and supply in
our business and it's taken me years to
really get a good grasp of what that
means especially for those of us who are
in the organic business for instance
let's take mangos what's the demand I
mean you have a huge conventional market
you have a very small organic market but
yet growers always think the demand is
this total number and so my question is
this whole demand and supply question
gets really confusing these the the
profit-driven response is so powerful
that people want to take this big pot
and say that's the demand when I think
it actually needs to be broken down and
a lot more regional scale than that and
I think that gets really confusing and
back to kind of his question where it
becomes difficult for growers to make a
living when they don't have real demands
numbers does that make any sense well I
think um anybody who's on the
procurement side you know influences
demand by the risks they sometimes take
in what they are buying and I think one
of the problems that we have are there's
not a lot of folks in procurement that
are brave enough to take those risks and
see what folks are not yet buying but
what they may and I think that is sort
of the bridge there and the way to get
across that bridge is communication with
those customers so someone put that out
there
Marco Rafi since mangos
well that's we know that consumer
awareness is very very important
I can see mango in supermarket and I can
see both Fairtrade one unconventional
one if I don't know what to do with
mango mango I won't buy and so and this
is why in supermarket in other places
people they try this sample it or the
harvest salsa something else introduced
it and get it out there but you are also
your question whether growers are
looking at the total amount of the
demand or not I don't I'm not occur but
I know that farmers they're very smart
farming is extremely difficult trade
very very difficult business to be in
they try to keep them self informed they
they get whatever information that is
out there to to make sure product that
they are producing is going to find a
market because their livelihood depends
on it
I have not found many farmers that were
confused about how much product they
need to put out there in the marketplace
they want to know that their products is
going to meet a certain price per pound
that's what what what is very very
important and there are institutional
buyers like our shop here at Yale we do
lid pricing we do contract pricing with
specific farmers and growers if they
need our specification and standards
it's Robert a fresh pot a question is I
guess about the raw materials and
Fairtrade whole trade and now we have a
new alliance program which talks about
raw ingredients and I guess as a
consumer you know we have more and more
brand branding kind of it gets a little
confusing I guess for the consumers and
I know that we it's not part of our job
to educate people and I think like even
you know it's like the next step above
Fairtrade it's supposed to be when the
product is not only grown in the area
but it's also produced and made in that
area employing more people so I guess my
question to the panel is is this you
know the difference between all these
different alliances and the different
things that we're creating I know that
it's innovative but it can also be
confusing at some point and also who's
regulating these these processes in this
foreign countries let me take on that
Fairtrade piece and that Patrick could
probably speak to this as well as
there's international labeling body
called flow a Fairtrade labeling
organization which is I believe based in
Europe internationally recognised
standard holders so anything that you
see in the United States that says
Fairtrade is based on the Fairtrade
labeling organizations standard which
the two key points that patrick said was
a social premium as well as a minimum
floor price but to your main point i I
don't want the proliferation of ethical
and transparent sourcing standards or
communications to hold us back yeah
there's a lot going on that's because
there's a lot of opportunities to fix up
in our supply chain and what we're
actually selling and it's contingent on
you know us as team members but also our
customers to stay educated you know
spread the word about what we can be
doing better and what we can be buying
because when you deal back that sort of
thin layer of what's really good there's
so much out there and you know most of
the dirt merchants of the world that's
really not so let's not hold ourselves
back
well at Whole Foods Market the whole
trade standard is based off of fair
trade essentially anything that's
exclusive sold only at Whole Foods is a
whole trade item in terms of anything
else that we communicated Whole Foods
Market it is always based off of another
recognized third party standard for
instance eco scale while we created it
we don't Aude it against it we utilize a
third-party named green seal to audit
against for instance non GMO anything
that is non GMO is actually verified by
the non-gmo project they give us a UPC
list of items that have gone through
their standards and that way we have
integrity in our processes may I ask a
question to follow up on his question
what you talked about basically is how
do you create standards that people can
understand and trust to designate
certain things like Fairtrade and that
I'm not in that area so I can't comment
on that in particular but at least in my
area the nutrition claims on food
products have been completely out of
control for many years because there's
so little government oversight on it and
consumers are completely confused you
know they see something that says no
trans fat when it never had trans fat to
begin with it's things like that and you
know the cereal is part of a nutritious
breakfast when it's you know half its
weight in sugar and things like that so
what I'm what I'm wondering is that you
guys see this as an impending threat as
as the the niche and the market of
people who care about these things grows
and grows there will be the tendency for
other players to come in and start to
abuse these sort of terms and labels and
things like that in a way that might
degrade the quality that these terms now
have and I just wondering if you you
guys perceive that as a threat or see
any way to hit it off at the past
because you can just imagine it coming
it's actually ongoing I think there is a
confusion over what the term natural
means and that's why we try to
differentiate you know at Whole Foods
Market
prioritize organics or looking at
different ways of communicating the
quality and the process involved in food
production in fact the impetus for us
designing eco scale was what we felt to
be a really weak cleaning standard
developed by another third-party
organization in the industry that was
essentially written by Clorox and we
said you know internally we need to do
better than that
we're not gonna wait for them to sort of
spell out to our customers what cleaning
product should be anybody else on this
we had a really interesting discussion
yesterday evening at the Yale Law School
that I was actually dealing with some of
the regulatory environment that either
gave credence or none at all to the
value of some of these labels basically
the public regulatory ability in this
country and in many other countries is
entirely inadequate to actually provide
the assurance that the consumers are
seeking and as has been discussed here
there's some labels that are basically
meaningless you know natural rising to
the top of that meaningless label list
there's others that have a lot behind
them you know organic has you know 600
plus pages of standards that are
actually detailed in great depth and the
producers are responsible to actually
pay for the verification for a third
party to come and actually see that all
those standards have been followed but
in those cases and what's being talked
about on the retail side as well it's
where the private sector has had to step
in to cover the gap which is not being
filled in public sector regulation and
you know that that creates a very uneasy
situation when you get into
international trade so the this is the
interesting opportunity that we have
right now is can the private sector
actually respond to that need for
verification along the whole supply
chain do it well do it with some level
of third-party involvement that can
actually reduce some of the inherent
conflict of interest that would be
involved in self-regulation and I think
that's kind of what we're talking about
right here with these mechanisms to see
can we do this because the public sector
is not able to they're just not given
the resources to actually regulate the
regulations that are in place
maybe we want to take a a list of
questions if somebody wants to go around
just so we don't miss anybody hi I'm
Jill from Paramus and the question is
either for error or marker both about
bio dynamics and I know in our store we
carry a lot of biodynamic wine but I
don't know what are the products or the
general questions biodynamic and how you
feel that the future of farming is going
to be affected by biodynamic
great question we actually just we're at
Expo East in Baltimore and we held a
seminar for about 150 of our grocery
suppliers presented by Demeter who's the
installer organism of sell organic
services to actually spur on the
development of more biodynamic grocery
products so stay tuned by Dynamix is
interesting it does actually have some
third-party certification behind the
practices through Demeter I think that
you'll see as the standard hopefully
evolves as the standard is raised
through this kind of mix of supply and
demand that you may actually find these
new kind of R&D related how can we push
the envelope a little bit further how
can we aspire to a higher standard and I
feel that bio Dominic is filling some of
that niche right now let's push the
envelope a little bit I would suspect
that you would find something kind of
similar a Beyond Organic a beyond local
a beyond grass-fed whatever that may be
arriving in the future and I I think
it's hopeful as we have certification on
some of these next level labels because
it means that we are actually evolving
and moving to different standards
back corner there so I'll get to you
next
I actually am from the Bellingham store
I actually just wanted to say thank you
for all of you for being here I was
afraid I was gonna run out of time I'm
watching you and I came here expecting
to just hear kind of numbers and and you
know it's like oh we're tossing these
ideas around and you're all actually on
the ground and running with these
programs and I'm impressed I thought I'd
be back here kind of snoozing a little
and and I'm delighted to find that
that's not the case and rafi and Kelly
I'm sorry I don't have your last names
really I'm impressed on what you're
doing with the youth and the public
policy and with your Dining Services
it's just amazing and I'm wondering how
are you educating the people with the
Dining Services I mean you're making an
impact in real time with your purchases
and lastly I'd like to know how can we
follow the group of you are you going to
make your information available to us
after we go home I'd like to see where
you're headed with all of this right if
you want to get that thank you
we we recognize that it's very very
important to educate our own staff first
okay if if we are to serve food 14,000
meals a day we have to make sure that
our ambassadors out there they're doing
the right thing in producing food in
making sure that they're communicating
the information in terms of putting
information for students themself about
three years ago four years ago
unfortunately the other thing that was
my mistake
we asked all our marketing dollars we
took all our marketing dollars and and
these were the day the years that we
instructed to cut back a little bit on
our food budget because of the
institution financial status and so and
the very first source that we could look
at and we said well let's get the
marketing dollars and put it back
actually in a food and not not scaled
back in terms of our specifications and
standards and we found ourselves three
years later that our students actually
did not know a thing about what we were
doing and so they were saying can we
have grass-fed beef we said we already
have it can we have natural chicken we
already have fresh chicken every frozen
can we have Connecticut dairy farms
organic this and that what we this is
already we doing that and they had no
idea they had no idea that these things
were and our focus was at the time that
you just do their I think you don't brag
about it you don't you don't talk about
it you just do it and and now we're
finding that we need to tell the story a
little bit more and that probably has an
area of vulnerability for us and we do
more work and educating the students and
providing them its information is
something that Mark and his team does
well and you know we were in the
business of doing food and making food
but they're in business of educating and
providing information and we are
collaborating and working toward that
end this question over here oh yeah hi
my name is Elaine and I'm from Prospect
Street in Cambridge Mass my question is
kind of more of a comment kind of geared
towards Kelly I think you might have a
little more faith in our government than
I do in the fact of thinking that
government regulations are gonna solve
some of our health problems and food
based problems you know just judging on
the fact that you know the high fructose
corn syrup in the corn industry and no
labeling of GMOs and all those kinds of
things so where I think it's good for
you know the government to be paying
more attention to school lunch programs
and things like that I really feel that
you know I think it a lot of it has to
come from you know us you know as
retailers as educators and things like
that I think we probably stand a chance
of doing a better job than the
government who has you know big
agriculture breathing down their necks
and all that kind of stuff so I was
wondering if you could just address that
a little more like how you think that
that's gonna play out and if you know
because maybe you have obviously have
more insights than I do but you kind of
scared me there for a second earlier on
faith would be hard to get out of bed
every morning I think if you look in the
health arena and that and I put I'm
we're looking at food for itself
consequences mainly just that's what we
do and I think you see a lot of
precedents where government has been
involved in in constructive ways in
health related things I mean public
health 101 sanitation immunizations
things like that government has done
extremely well they've done a very good
job except for some recent failures with
food safety issues for the most part
there's some fortification successes and
the food supply so there are some things
government has done well not to say that
there aren't some things that really is
messed up in a very bad way as well but
take tobacco as an example the greatest
public health victory of the last
century in this country was cutting the
number of people who smoked more than in
half and that was government action it
was taxes it was Clean Indoor Air Act's
it was things that government did that
started locally and so it wasn't the
federal government the federal
government was a last body of government
to act on tobacco because the lobbying
pressures you mentioned but it was
little towns in California that started
agitating and passing laws that then
spread to other little towns that then
spread the larger cities then the state
started to act and finally the federal
government caught up we're seeing
exactly that same process occurring with
food-related issues it's it's the local
governments and state governments that
are taking actions first and then it
spreads to the national government
school nutrition is a great example of
that lots of local action now there's a
new law that's that and one of the
heroes on this by the way happens to be
our representative here rosa DeLauro
she's the best person the whole house of
representatives on these issues there's
great school nutrition legislation about
to kick in
there's menu labeling where calories are
gonna have to be posted in restaurants
that's a national law but it started
locally in New York City first and so
these local things are tremendously
important so what people do on the
ground in their localities is very
important and one of the things that I
would urge you all to consider is that
to take the citizens who we can educate
to care about these food issues not only
in their own lives but to activate them
as political citizens and to show
individuals that they can have a voice
with a School Board for example or with
their state legislators then you can get
legislative action that's constructive I
work with various segments of the
industry and one thing that you
consistently hear the industry does not
want to have regulation but at the same
time they do want to have regulation so
why why why this two-sided approach from
one side industry does not want to get
regulated by government because they say
what government doesn't know what
government does and so why would they
regulate us and well the only other
thing let's say on the trans-fats
and the example was the city of the New
York has started with that initiative
and labeling requirement and then it
became national that was a good thing
for the industry the initiative now
regarding salt you know the salt
initiative is extremely important and
there is a lot of forces a lot of people
in the industry they are trying to
reduce the amount of salt in the food
that is not going to happen if it's not
some sort of policy supports behind it
and and but once the policy supports get
behind that the industry will comply and
will happen across the board the quality
of their sugar and the quality of
carbohydrates that's another thing that
the industry is willing to do something
about it but if there is no e
equalization of the field so if I'm
factory a and I can put as much salt or
sugar I want in my product and factory B
is not doing it we're not competing in
in the marketplace in on the equal basis
so there you really need to have some
sort of policy support and resource
everybody needs to Google proposition 37
in California sir
I'm Tony I'm from the symphony store I'd
also like to thank you for being here
today this is great this is really
informative however to piggyback on
Elaine's comments I think there's a long
long road ahead of us we have a have a
lot to do so but you know it's estimated
still for everyone's hard work that's
seventy five percent of government
subsidies still go to meat dairy fats
sugar and alcohol lobbyists raised
millions of dollars for those got milk
celebrity campaigns the USDA is just
switched from the food pyramid which
we've been so used to to the new MyPlate
system of fruits vegetables grains
protein and dairy
there's been a lot of discussion about
the proportions the inclusion of dairy I
guess I'd like to get the panel's a
panel's opinion on how how they feel
about that and the new the new program
that's being rolled out by the USDA what
was exactly your question what is a
panel members opinion of the new MyPlate
system that's been rolled out by the
USDA rather than the you know
traditional food pyramid that we've had
in the past thank you improvement over
some of the food pyramid and food things
that have existed in the past
primarily because the food industry is
having less and less influence as we go
forward in time it doesn't mean it's
removed by all means but it's less than
it used to be which used to be
ridiculous and so the MyPlate is a big
improvement not only on the graphic but
in
the nutrition criteria that underlie but
as a general rule I think what we're
gonna see here but like this is just my
own guess and you know what's that worth
but I think we're seeing progress in in
lines that look like this and then I
think the tipping point thing is going
to kick in at some point and we're gonna
get big progress all of a sudden and
what makes me think that if you look at
what happened in the tobacco field it
took 40 years I mean this first Surgeon
General's report showing that smoking
was causing lung cancer it was in 1964
the decades after that before needed
public policy kicked in but if you go
back through that developmental history
of what occurred all those steps that
were that were seen back then or
occurring now in the food arena but
they're happening much more quickly and
so that the 30 or 40 year history seems
to be compressed and food and you're
starting to see more and more people get
interested in this and if we can harness
that interest in the right way then I
think we will hit these tipping points
then you'll see a lot of change all of a
sudden in the back
thank you for all being here it's
pleasure to hear from all of you talking
and thinking about sustainability and
really thinking about it carefully as
mr. mark said it brings us to a lot of
global and detailed issues if I ask you
about the political side of dealing with
big corporations that does not support
sustainability other than educating
customers and dealing with government
policies is there any other strategies
that you are working with in regards to
dealing with big corporations that does
not support sustainability I can start
with that one since I guess Whole Foods
is technically one of those big
corporations but we also do buy and sell
product that is made by coca-cola Pepsi
Nestle Unilever Kraft Foods etc and so
we have the same discussions with the
large consumer packaged goods companies
or cpgs as we call them as we do with
small suppliers and we make a decision
based on their response to those
questions and to how they prioritize our
relationship on how we move forward and
some of them are not doing as well as
they used to and that's what I'll say
I'll give you an example which is pretty
much public knowledge is about three
years ago that we had had some really
intense discussions with White Way foods
who made a silk soy milk about their
soybeans sourcing the fact that they had
switched from an organic domestically
grown soybean source to a conventional
source from China without changing the
packaging it was the same packaging that
some of us who had been you know silk
fans for a long time I grown up on and
we let them know that we weren't happy
with that and over the course of a few
months developed some alternative
products and in the summer of 2010
pulled silk off our shelves and
introduced a bunch of organic products
soy milk and almond milk and our
business got a lot better after that and
our customers responded really well and
so there's a lot of other examples we
have at Whole Foods of doing that and
that's basically back to the point of
our core values and understanding what
our customers are looking for but also I
want to point out your consumers and
your citizens and making sure that that
communication you're letting your
retailers know you're letting folks who
are buying food and working with them
because they don't always hear and so
it's really good to keep your mouth open
anyone else want to take that I think I
think the approach is you you want to be
working with all the audiences you want
to be working with the system at very
very different scales simultaneously
when you look at again some of these
small scale successes the things that
are happening on the very very cutting
edge you know they're doing wonderful
things and having impacts but they're
having impacts within such a narrow
sphere and if you extrapolate even
wonderful growth in some of these areas
you still don't get any you know pending
unseating of the Coca Cola's and the
Unilever is if you just kind of continue
on the math of saying okay if this
wonderfully highest standard sector
continues this 20% growth etc etc you're
still looking at well maybe sometime two
centuries from now that we might have
this replacing the Unilever to the world
so I think that's why holding out the
hope to say if we can have a small
reform within a very very large sphere
in a large corporation that has a very
large impact that's kind of why we're
hoping to work on all scales and figure
out if we actually use those larger
players for the larger reforms even if
they tend to be a little bit modest
within the overall operations and so
it's kind of interesting that even
within a company like Unilever there
still is within a pocket of that company
some very cutting edge sustainability
work happening doing some research
funding research outside of Unilever
which actually looks very good compared
to some of the things that you can get
within a publicly funded University
you're finding grad students who are
doing amazing work funded by Unilever
you're doing you're having some of the
companies that they service who are
doing some amazing reforms those have
not rolled out across the
company by any means but seeing these
small pockets of success even within the
big companies I think gives reason to
hold out hope because again whether it's
a big public policy a small change over
this broad spectrum can actually yield
in some larger impacts so I think we
have to be working on them at both scale
simultaneously well we've been given the
notice to wrap up so I want to
appreciate the panel here who has both
been for me both inspirational and
informational and I'm really hoping
everybody here will be taking this
knowledge home with you and out into the
streets and out into your habits and
things that you do on a daily basis and
continuing to push these issues forward
and make these changes that we need to
because our our role really depends on
it we